claude blanchemaison bonjour ravi de
vous retrouver dans la matinale de rtl
france de bonheur alors est ce que le
cycle des sanctions et contre sanctions
commerciales va s'arrêter avec
l'administration joe biden écoutez oui
manifestement pour l'union européenne
l'élection de joe biden est un
soulagement puisque donald trump et les
mets pas tout ce qui était des râles et
particulièrement l'union européenne est
en effet en 2018 il avait décidé d'une
première série de sanctions tarifaires
décembre des droits de douane punitifs
25% sur l'acier 10% sur l'aluminium et
puis ensuite à la suite d'une décision
de l'organisation mondiale de commerce
décision tardive sur les subventions que
les européens donnent airbus et que les
américains donné à brigue
eh bien les américains sur le fond de
cette décision de l'om c'est ont mis des
droits de douane 25% sur les vins et les
fromages donc ça affecte directement la
france mais aussi l'italie et puis il
des droites oise sur d'autres produits
donc la première question qui se pose
est est ce que on est en état de se
débarrasser de ces droits de douane
punitifs américain d'ailleurs l'union
européenne s'est montrée bonne joueuse
puisque elle a suspendu les mesures
réciproques auxquelles avait autorisé
l'organisation mondiale du commerce au
titre de subventions dont boeing avait
bénéficié de la part du gouvernement
fédéral américain
donc la réplique de l'union européenne
est suspendu suspendu à premier réaction
de l'administration by day il est
probable que l'administration byden va
prendre le sujet par le biais politique
est en effet assez vite maiden viendra à
bruxelles peut être d'ailleurs dans le
double objectif de rassurer ses
partenaires de l'otan et
de rassurer l'union européenne en tant
que telle et en prenant la chose par le
biais politique il n'est pas sûr que il
lève tout de suite les droits de douane
punitifs que donald trump avait avait
avait instauré d'ailleurs il est
également possible que la nouvelle
administration américaine cherche dans
le fond la solution dans une fuite en
avant puisque il était question il y a
quelques années d'un accord de
coopération même d'un accord de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et les
etats unis
là-dessus l'union européenne a une
vision un peu contrastée parce que
pourquoi pas à un accord facilitant les
échanges entre les états unis l'union
européenne
mais à quelques conditions naturellement
la première étant que les états unis
ouvrent leurs marchés publics aux
entreprises aux entreprises européennes
et puis il ya aussi les sanctions à
niang
lorsque les états unis mettent des
sanctions sur l'iran eh bien ils
attendent des entreprises européennes
qu'elles n'appliquent ces sanctions
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'extra
territorialité des décisions américaines
et si elles ne le font pas et bien les
américains les les sanctionne sur le
marché américain
et c'est pour cette raison que psa
renault total ont dû se retirer du
marché iranien
donc ceci est évidemment totalement
inacceptable et doit être qui doit être
discutée avec la nouvelle administration
by day ce ne sera pas facile
est-ce que l'autonomie stratégie voulue
par emmanuel macron va survivre en
europe claude à l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
administration
ce sera aussi une difficulté puisque
bien sûr cette nouvelle souveraineté
stratégique s'est manifestée la
meilleure manifestation était la
conclusion d'un accord sur les
investissements avec la chine il ya très
peu de temps malgré
les remarques de l'administration
américaine
et bien cet accord a été conclu et
conclue dans le fonds au bénéfice des
deux parties puisque ça permet d'ouvrir
certains secteurs chinois aux
entreprises françaises pourraient bien
entendu voir comment cela se traduit
dans la pratique est là encore avec la
chine il n'est pas question de faire
preuve de naïveté
mais il est vrai que pour l'avenir les
états unis souhaiteront une plus grosse
coordination une plus grande
coordination entre les actions de
l'union européenne et les actions de la
russie union européenne veut et doit
garder son autonomie de décision mais
elle l'a montré par rapport à la chine
elle doit le montrer aussi par rapport à
la russie par rapport à la turquie par
rapport à aux divers événements autour
du bassin méditerranéen
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison pour
cet éclairage le rappelle on vous
retrouve un tous les mercredis matin
dans la matinale de rtl france